against what was then China's capital
city Nanking in the late 1930s two
decades past
iris graduated from the University of
Illinois and went on to earn a master's
degree at Johns Hopkins she married her
college sweetheart and published a
biography on the scientist who developed
China's missile program then in 1994
iris attended a conference in Northern
California on Japanese war atrocities
and saw poster sized photos of Nanking
victims mutilated in tortured bodies
rape victims forced into pornographic
poses faces contorted into unforgettable
expressions of terror and shame
iris finally saw with her own eyes what
her parents had told her about and she
found herself in a panic a panic born in
the fear that the massacre would forever
be just a footnote in history or even
worse just as some would have us believe
that the Holocaust against Jews never
happened in Nazi Germany that some
Japanese politicians continue to deny
the carnage that took place in Nanking
fortunately iris Chang's book The Rape
of Nanking The Forgotten Holocaust of
World War two is making that denial hard
to fathom the massacre at Nanking is not
just a footnote anymore the book
followed two years of research iris iris
interviewed survivors and Japanese army
veterans she read diaries of American
missionaries and other foreigners and
Nanking at the time and she read
newspaper and military accounts the work
was so painful that iris lost a lot of
her hair and a lot of her weight The
Rape of Nanking tells the story of a
massacre where as many as 350,000 men
women and children were slaughtered in a
six to eight week period more lives were
lost an end Qing than during the atomic
bombings of Nagasaki and Hiroshima
combined but The Rape of Nanking does
more does a lot more than simply narrate
details of barbarism and tragedy the
book looks at the militaristic culture
that allowed for a total disregard of
human life and it tells the story of the
second rape how the Cold War led to a
concerted effort by the West and even
China to stifle discussion of what had
happened in Nanking and the rest of the
country during the Japanese
invasion since the book's publication
iris has had a grueling schedule of
readings interviews and speaking
engagements what keeps her going as she
told a newspaper reported this past
summer I am giving voice to hundreds of
thousands of people who perished in 1937
and who are not as lucky as me had I
been born at the wrong time the wrong
place the wrong country I could have
easily been one of the victims I could
have won I could have been one of the
nameless bodies heaped in some nameless
pile of corpses and those photos and I
would not want to be forgotten I do this
for them and she did it for us Thank You
iris
greetings it's great honor to be here
and I want to thank all of you for
coming here to learn about a side of
World War two history that some of you
may be hearing about for the first time
I plan to speak for about half an hour
I'm going to leave 15 minutes for
questions and and that I'd be glad to
answer when we all think of World War 2
I think that we tend not to think of the
Asian side of of the war at the time you
know we we tend to think of the European
Holocaust d-day if we do think of the
the Asian theater at all we tend to
visualize the mushroom clouds over
Hiroshima and Nagasaki so I think that
many Americans are truly not aware of
the full story of the Pacific side to
world war two and by this I mean the
atrocities committed by the Japanese
armies against millions of Chinese
people Southeast Asians Koreans
Filipinos and even our own American
citizens now during World War two
Japan's invasion of China launched an
eight-year war which ultimately killed
an estimated 19 million 235 million
Chinese people and during this time the
Japanese military also lured purchased
or kidnapped hundreds of thousands of
women for sexual slavery for their
Imperial Army women who were subjected
to some of the most horrifying
experiences inflicted upon military
prostitutes in history what I plan to do
this morning is use The Rape of Nanking
the subject of my new book as just one
example to illustrate what the Japanese
did in many of the regions that they
conquered I'll also show some of the
glaring scars that were left behind
which persists to this very day about 61
years ago in December of 1937 the
Japanese Imperial Army invaded the city
Nanking which was then the seat of the
nationalist government in China as well
as the capital of mainland China and
within a six to eight week period the
Japanese army not only looted and burned
this defenseless City but systematically
raped tortured and murdered some 300,000
Chinese civilians it's very hard I think
for all of us and just to conceptualize
300,000 deaths until we put this number
in the context of world history more
people would die from The Rape of
Nanking then from the atomic blasts at
Hiroshima and Nagasaki combined in fact
the death toll of Nanking just one
Chinese city alone during six to eight
weeks far exceeded the total civilian
casualty count of three European
countries combined for all of World War
two
England France and Belgium so it's
important to realize that Nanking is
already one of the greatest atrocities
world history and yet it is just one
small fraction of the atrocities that
were perpetrated across Asia and of
course in China by the Japanese armies
which had killed perhaps as many as 35
million Chinese people but numbers don't
tell the full story of The Rape of
Nanking you really can't measure the
degree of torture and suffering that was
inflicted upon the civilians in that
city there were stories of women who
were nailed to walls and impaled after
being raped or nailed to boards and run
over by army tanks there were stories of
people being hanged by their tongues on
iron hooks or buried waist down in the
soil so they could be ripped apart by
German shepherds even small children
weren't spared the carnage at Nanking
babies were tossed in the air and
bayonetted on the way down or thrown
alive into vats of boiling water
indeed the orgy of violence would prove
to be so brutal in the city that even
the Nazi Party members in Nanking were
shocked at the spectacle now The Rape of
Nanking was not what many Japanese
revisionists claimed today a massacre
that was perpetrated in the heat of
battle in which some innocent civilians
got caught in the crossfire
this was a cold and systematic Massacre
that was portrayed it against thousands
of Chinese civilians and Chinese unarmed
POWs who had already thrown away their
weapons and surrendered after the city
fell the Japanese military had issued a
kill all captives order at the time
which seems to have come as a directive
from some of the highest levels of
military power and the Japanese soldiers
carried out this order systematically
and within the first few days the
massacre the army rounded up tens of
thousands of men and herded them into
warehouses and then led them out at
remote areas of the city after the men
had permitted their hands to be tied
behind their backs and across the city
the army machine gunned tens of
thousands of Chinese men or buried them
alive or used them for bayonet practice
or decapitation contests or thousands of
men were simply sprayed with gasoline
and set on fire now most of these
executions were efficient but there were
men who died under the most slow
sadistic and excruciating ly painful
circumstances when Japanese soldiers
turned murder into sport there were
cases of Chinese men who were skinned
alive crucified bricked to death by
needles and even cannibalized and so
many men were killed during those first
few days of massacre that the Japanese
army literally had problems disposing of
all of the corpses burial of course was
one method
a Japanese general was soon complaining
in his diary that they had run out of
ditches large enough to hold seven or
eight thousand corpses at a time a
cremation was another method but the
Japanese army soon ran out of gasoline
so they were left with mountains of
charred flesh in the end many bodies
thousands of bodies were simply dumped
into the Yangtze River the waters of
which were filled with bloated corpses
and ran red with blood for days
after killing most of the men in the
city in this fashion the Japanese army
then turned their attention on the
Chinese women making the Rape of Nanking
the single greatest mass rape of world
history up to that moment it is now the
second worst mass rape of world history
second only to the wholesale violation
of bengali women by Pakistani soldiers
in the 1970s after a failed rebellion in
the city of Nanking no woman was safe
Japanese soldiers raped
great-grandmother's over the ages of 80
along with children under the ages of 8
often victims were raped in broad
daylight in front of hundreds of
pedestrians often in the middle of
streets and the army did more than just
rape women but and girls but often
mutilated them horribly with tree
branches bayonets swords golf sticks and
even lit firecrackers there were even
stories of soldiers who sliced open
small children to ravish them more
effectively and even stories of pregnant
women who are gang-raped before the
fetuses were torn out of their bellies
as trophies and these aren't even some
of the worst stories Chinese sons were
sometimes even forced to rape their own
mother's or Father's their own daughters
or brothers their own sisters as other
family members watched those who refused
were usually killed on the spot in the
end the Japanese raped more than 20,000
women
girls Nanking and some estimate that the
figure is probably as high as 80,000
women and girls but I think the full
effects of the rape can't be measured on
a tally sheet of Statistics because many
of the women who survived weeks of gang
rape found themselves pregnant
afterwards and therefore faced the
choice of committing infanticide or
rearing half Japanese children that they
could never love and I think that many
Chinese women simply could not make that
choice nor could they live with the
trauma of what they had endured and four
months after the great Rape of Nanking
it was observed that countless numbers
of women in the city were simply taking
their own lives by fleeing themselves
into the Yangtze River but The Rape of
Nanking did more than destroy the lives
of individual women in the city it also
appears to have resulted in an
underground system of military
prostitution which destroyed the lives
of hundreds of thousands of women across
Asia The Rape of Nanking had created a
huge public outcry among Western nations
at the time and this was front-page news
in the new york times and many other
Western papers and it's believed that it
caused such bad press for the Japanese
government that the government tried to
control the libido of the Japanese
soldiers by creating their own
prostitution ring which we now know as
the comfort women system or the Korean
comfort women system an estimated
200-thousand women most of them Korean
women but many also from other Asian
countries some of whom were also
Caucasian such as Dutch women were
forced to serve in what the Japanese
government called facilities of sexual
comfort to stop troops from raping women
in regions that they controlled in China
the Japanese established their first
comfort station between Nanking and
Shanghai shortly after the Nanking
Massacre in 1938
many of these comfort women were only
you know teenagers or even children when
they were captured and they were often
attacked by as many as twenty thirty or
fifty men a night every night for years
during the war and untold numbers of
these women whom the Japanese army
called public toilets took their own
lives when they learned their destiny
and and countless others died from
outright murder or disease indeed only
one in four comfort women survived the
experience and if many of you are
learning about this for the first time
it is because the first comfort women
did not step forward to tell their
stories until the early 90s and and
their stories were so horrific that when
one comfort woman went to the Justice
Department to disclose what had happened
to her many of the men in the audience
most of them hardened Nazi war criminal
hunters found themselves in tears I
don't think there was a dry eye in the
audience now decades later the Japanese
government tried to insist that these
brothels were run by private
entrepreneurs and not the wartime
government but just a few years ago a
Japanese professor by the name of dr.
Yoshi akka yahoo Chiaki
yo Shima Acho University found
undeniable evidence in the Japanese
government archives that the entire
system was indeed authorized by
officials of the Japanese High Command
and this man as professor found
documents bearing the stamps and seals
of some of the most powerful Japanese
members in government at the time so
that does make the wartime government
responsible and you know I can't
possibly mention all the atrocities that
were committed by the Japanese armies
throughout China or even just in the
city of Nanking because of time
limitations but I will mention however a
little about the josef mengele like
medical experimentation
that was inflicted upon Nanking
civilians after the massacre and
elsewhere in China such as the notorious
unit 731 laboratory in Manchuria in the
city of Nanking the Japanese operated a
secret medical lab codenamed AI 1644 in
which they fed human guinea pigs or with
cyanide snake poison germs and lethal
gases Japanese doctors working at the
secret lab killed about 10 people weekly
in this manner and incinerated the
bodies but in unit 731 which was not in
Nanking but in Manchuria the Japanese
doctors killed even more people
performing horrendous experiments and
even vivisection without anesthesia on
both American and Chinese prisoners and
again if some of you are hearing about
this for the first time it is because a
lot of this was covered up actually by
our own government after the war the US
government actually exonerated the
Japanese doctors responsible for
committing these atrocities in exchange
for their medical data which was often
attained at this expense of American
POWs and these Japanese doctors went
back to Japan where they then assumed
powerful positions in government
academia and business some even became
founders and executives at the Green
Cross blood processing plant which is
now defunct a corporation which was
caught a few years ago selling HIV
tainted blood to Japanese haemophiliac
patients so the victims of this medical
experimentation involved not only
American and Chinese victims but
Japanese victims as well were simply not
informed of the backgrounds of some of
the leading members of the Japanese
medical establishment in some when you
look back on all of these atrocities you
would think that was such a record that
the Japanese government would have shown
proper remorse a long time ago for the
genocide that was perpetrated across
Asia
but that's not the situation at all to
this very day the Japanese government
takes very little responsibility for
these atrocities even though the wartime
government had given the orders to
commit them and there have even been
politicians in Japan who have gone on
the record in the last few years to deny
that any of these atrocities happened at
all this is why I believe that the story
of The Rape of Nanking and the story of
other atrocities is really the story of
two rapes the first rape happened 60
years ago but the second rape is ongoing
and it is the rape of history and the
rape of justice over the last 60 years
Japan is almost completely escaped the
moral and financial responsibility that
their counterparts in Germany had to
face over and over again let's just give
out a few examples in the realm of
apologies we all know that Germany has
made several profuse apologies to their
wartime victims but the Japanese
government has yet to deliver one
sincere apology directly to the
survivors of the Nanking Massacre or to
their families and the some of the
apologies that they claimed to have made
to the wartime victims in general have
often avoided the word use of the words
apologies in general preferring words
like remorse or regret and is not really
deemed as sincere by many of the victims
of the Japanese across Asia now as many
of you who've been following the news
may know a few weeks ago Japan has made
a written apology to the South Korean
government and a similar apology was
promised to the Chinese government and
we'll see what will happen in just about
a week when Gyeongju Ming visits Tokyo
because that's when the prompt the
apology is supposedly going to be
delivered now in the realm of war
restitution the differences between how
the two countries have dealt with their
wartime past loom large the Germans have
paid the equivalent of about 60 billion
u.s. dollars
in war reparations to their victims and
will continue to pay several more
billion by the year 2005 but the
Japanese government has paid close to
nothing and certainly not one penny in
reparations to the victims of Nanking
what's even more disturbing I think is
how the subject of World War two is
taught in schools in both countries the
Germans have required by law the
teaching of the history of the Jewish
Holocaust in their schools and any
teacher who refuses to participate or
neglects to teach this history is simply
breaking the law but the Japanese
government far from mandating the study
of their World War two aggression has
through the Ministry of Education openly
impeded the experts of textbook authors
to do so in that country and have even
censored whitewashed or distorted
details of the Nanking atrocities and
other work time crimes from school
textbooks despite a three decade-long
lawsuit waged against the Ministry of
Education by textbook author and
historian
Anagha Saburo to such an extent that
many people who have gone through the
Japanese school system are not even
quite aware of what exactly happened
during World War two in fact I had the
opportunity to talk with the Japanese
college professor who told me that many
students in his class that actually
approached him was a question of we know
that the Japan and the u.s. had been at
war during you know the Second World War
but which side won so I think that
whatever is being done in terms of
public education in Japan is simply not
adequate but there's also a revisionist
movement in Japan underway in in Germany
when you look at Germany they've simply
made it illegal in their country to
openly deny the existence of the
Holocaust but in Japan legions of
professors filmmakers journalists and
even leading members of government
have openly proclaimed that The Rape of
Nanking and other war atrocities never
happened at all or were minor incidents
much overblown there is a vocal minority
of activists and scholars in Japan who
openly refute this view and they have
worked hard to raise awareness of
Japan's wartime past in that country and
have published books on the subject and
as well as brought litigation against
the government on behalf of the victims
but some of these individuals have faced
ostracism death threats and even
assassination attempts from members of
the ultra nationalist fanatics
infections in Japan for example just a
few years ago the mayor of Nagasaki was
shot in the chest
merrily for stating his belief publicly
that Emperor Hirohito bore some
responsibility for World War two and
while Nazi war criminals are vilified in
Germany and seen as the source of great
national shame Japanese class-a war
criminals are worshipped as deities in
the Yasukuni Shrine in Tokyo a practice
which is not only morally reprehensible
but indeed the source of tremendous
anguish to wartime victims across Asia
and I think it's something that would
never be tolerated if it's parallel were
practiced in Europe the worship of these
men in the Yasukuni Shrine is the moral
and political equivalent of moving
statues of Hitler's cronies and leading
wartime criminals into the biggest
cathedral of Berlin and honoring these
men as gods at this point the question
inevitably arises which is how did all
of this happen I mean why do differences
in post-war behavior looms so large
between Germany and Japan and the answer
I believe really lies in the Cold War
after 1949 neither Chinese government
neither the People's Republic of China
nor the Republic of China
based in Taiwan wanted to push Japan for
apologies or reparations or to broadcast
news of these atrocities worldwide
because both governments were competing
for Japan's diplomatic and political
recognition the United States government
also failed to pursue the issue because
it saw Japan as potentially a stable
base that they could build up to counter
the forces of communism in the Soviet
Union and in Asia so Cold War concerns
in the United States the People's
Republic of China and the Republic of
China and Taiwan
really overrode the need to press for
justice for the victims and as a result
many of the worst wartime criminals in
Japan escaped prosecution and Punishment
entirely unlike the Nazi leaders of
Germany who are mostly imprisoned
executed or at the very least forced to
live out the rest of their days as
fugitives from Alois the entire Japanese
royal family including Emperor Hirohito
was exonerated under the terms of the
surrender and was held exempt from
having to face prosecution or even to
testify as witnesses during the
International Military Tribunal of the
Far East often known as the Asian
equivalent of the Nuremberg trials
moreover the entire Japanese wartime
bureaucracy remained intact so that
those who had plunged the country into
war in the first place were permitted
thanks to American leniency to stay in
power after the war therefore many of
those officials were left in a position
to control what was taught about World
War two in Japanese schools or what
would filter through the media to the
Japanese people and even today the
bitter legacy of Japan's World War 2
past and persistent refusals in that
country to admit wrongdoing still haunts
the island nation and her neighbors
especially during a time of financial
crisis when the need for reconciliation
is more important than ever
a revisionist movement still thrives in
Japan to deny all wartime wrongdoing and
this only exacerbates the old wounds and
tensions between Japan and her neighbors
let me give you just a few examples of
this revisionist movement for instance
in May of this year a major Japanese
studio released the movie pride an
instant in a lifetime which not only
depicts the Japanese wartime leader Tojo
as a hero and a martyr but also implies
as well that the rape of man King never
happened at all this movie became the
top grossing film in Japan for the year
but when another movie called 19 1937
which was produced outside of Japan but
shown within Japanese theaters this
summer right-wing ultra nationalist
extremists not only issued death threats
to at least one theater owners family
but slashed up his screens with a knife
indeed the police had to be called to
protect many of the theater goers as
right-wingers demonstrated outside
meanwhile in June of this year six
Japanese revisionist academics held a
conference in Tokyo to deny the entire
existence of the Nanking Massacre some
even insisted that it was the Chinese
who did all the looting raping and
murdering in the city and that it was
the Chinese who had quote unilaterally
massacred all of the Japanese up to that
point even though they never explained
what the Japanese army was doing in
China in the first place and that civic
life in Nanking actually improved by
leaps and bounds once the friendly
soothing Japanese soldiers arrived in
the city unfortunately a mountain of
evidence on the Nanking Massacre which
includes thousands of pages of primary
source documents in four different
languages English German Chinese
Japanese that were generated during the
event as it happened all of this
evidence has not deterred extremists in
Japan from dismissing it all as
propaganda or as forgeries and
in this way the spin strategies of these
revisionists are really no different
from that of Holocaust deniers or
Armenian Genocide deniers and Turkey the
latter of which as in Japan include
powerful members of Turkish society
what's very disturbing in Japan is that
some of the revisionists occupy very
powerful positions in in government or
academia they are not they have not been
relegated to the fringes of society one
of them in fact happens to be a
professor of education at Tokyo
University which is considered the most
prestigious university in the country I
personally believe that Japan in the
face of this revisionist movement really
needs to do four things if it is to
redeem itself to the international
community first of all it has to give
sincere unequivocal apologies to all
surviving wartime victims instead of the
vague expressions of remorse that have
been made in the past secondly it should
pay in full the reparations owed to
wartime victims thirdly and I probably
most importantly it should stop
censoring or whitewashing its war crimes
in school textbooks
I don't think Japan can move forward as
a nation until it educates its young
about the truth the whole truth and
nothing but the truth about its wartime
aggression starting with Nanking any
country that refuses to disclose basic
historical facts to its people a country
that rewrites history for its people is
the country that jeopardizes its very
future as a democracy as well as dooming
itself to potentially repeating the
mistakes of the past and fourthly I
think Japan should open up all its
wartime archives for review by an
international coalition of historians
most of these archives are under lock
and key now after the US government in
the 1950s mysteriously returned to Japan
the high-level Japanese military
documents that American occupation
forces had seized from that country a
decade later and these records returned
without being properly micro filmed I
think we have to be vigilant
people to ensure that accurate records
of all war crimes be preserved for a
global audience I think Steven Spielberg
for example has done a wonderful thing
by creating the Shoah foundation to film
the surviving testimonials of Holocaust
victims and I think that historians
should follow his lead and gather
eyewitness accounts of Japanese
brutality through an international oral
history videotape project which would
create an even richer archive of primary
source material for future books this
would protect the victims from being
written out of history by future
revisionists and there's a very small
window of opportunity to do this because
the victims are dying most of the ones
who had survived the massacre already in
their not 80s
it must be stressed that we need such a
repository of history to constantly
remind ourselves of the human potential
for evil Japan is not uniquely capable
of these kinds of atrocities nor are
they the first country to evade
punishment for their crimes
so we fool ourselves when we declare
that atrocity a genocide is some kind of
unique aberration in the history of
mankind this is not an isolated incident
or some deadly flaw of one country or
culture but a universal condition of
human nature when we look back on the
20th century which you realize that this
has been the bloodiest century of all
time and in this century alone we've
seen not only attempts to exterminate
entire races through the Holocaust and
the Armenian Genocide the wholesale
massacres of millions of people by
dictators like Stalin Mao and Pol Pot
and I think as we approach the next
millennium we would like to believe that
it couldn't happen again but statistic
after statistic cry out to us that they
could and we're still seeing brutality
in the world reminiscent of that of the
rape of name King in countries like
Bosnia Rwanda and most recently
Indonesia where rape is being used as a
weapon to intimidate the local Chinese
people as well as the threatened
Human Rights volunteers from testifying
about these crimes the UN I really think
that the best antidotes to genocide are
the troops the forces of truth and
conscience and democracy I think by
honestly viewing The Rape of Nanking as
a cautionary tale in history I think
that the Chinese the Americans the
Japanese and other Asian countries can
honestly start to work together towards
this very difficult task of remembrance
so they can work towards a goal that can
promote not hatred but healing and
towards the kind of dialogue that would
help them avoid recreating these
conditions that gave rise to war in the
first place
I think as members of the human race
these Horrors can't be denied or
forgotten not at the peril of human
civilization itself I think we all have
a moral responsibility to remind
remember such crimes against humanity
and to force countries like Japan to
face up to these crimes and to try to
prevent atrocities like The Rape of
Nanking from ever happening again thank
you so much for your time today
we have a few minutes for questions now
um in I've been reading about your book
tremendously of it since it came out and
it seems like you really compiled a
tremendous amount of information here
and now hearing from you it also seems
that there was a tremendous amount of
resistance in in you know allowing this
information to come forwards and denying
it and I'm curious as to what kind of
resistance you encountered and how you
compiled this research and whether you
know you've been threatened and and just
you know the resistance that you
experienced in putting this whole book
together I haven't received any threats
and I didn't really receive any
resistance in doing research because a
lot of this material was already
available in like American archives and
I when I went to the People's Republic
of China I quietly networked with the
the scholars and historians who brought
me to some of the the victims so I I
didn't really receive any kind of
obstacles I did not go to Japan by did
correspond with Japanese scholars and
also with a veteran who had actually
perpetrated many of these atrocities and
felt it was important and burden himself
and through that person I had a chance
to really understand I think to a little
better degree the the psyche of some of
the soldiers at that time of course
there has been a tremendous reaction to
this book after it came out
I've been lampooned in Japanese
political cartoons and I've been
vilified in editorials those six
revisionist academics who held that
press conference to claim that The Rape
of Nanking ever happened they also
called my book the most outrageous
world-class lie in the spring of this
year the Japanese ambassador to the
United States even came out and
denounced the book as one sided
erroneous and filled with historical
inaccuracies even though he was not able
to come up with a single good example to
illustrate any inaccuracies in my book
and of course what he said
provoked a very strong response for many
organizations and and like the Simon
Wiesenthal Center the People's Republic
of China my publisher several human
rights groups all issued strong Li
worded protest letters to the Japanese
government and to the Ambassador and
they also demanded that he specify what
he meant and at the time I you know I
think he even issued a statement to the
effect that it's not the Japanese
government's job to specify what an iris
Chang's book is inaccurate
that's the job for left up best left up
to historians but when you make a
statement like this I think you the
burden of proof is on you
so it's no exaggeration to say that that
there has been extreme resistance to
this book I mean in Japan on the other
hand as I mentioned before my speech
there was a vocal minority of people who
are ready working hard to raise public
awareness on this and of course they
have championed the book so so this book
will be published in Japanese this this
winter by the Kashiwa show about
publishing house I think they're
extremely courageous undertake this
because as one editor wrote to me an
email day he said it was no exaggeration
that the publishing company had put
themselves in a life-threatening
situation just by publishing this book
so I commend their courage and I think
that once it comes out it should be very
interesting to watch the reaction in
Japan thank you for the tremendous
service you've done thank you
have you been invited to Tokyo ine group
I haven't received any invitations that
I'm aware of
Oh
and among historians have been other
works either preceding or now being
worked on to corroborate and expand upon
your work oh yeah
back in the 1930s there were some
monographs that were published to
reprint some of the documents that were
generated by by American missionaries
and Westerners at the time I don't think
they were widely circulated though but
one thing I didn't mention in my speech
was the fact that there were about about
22 Western foreigners American
missionaries German businessmen who were
also Nazi Party members ironically
Russians and Danes who stayed in the
city to create a safety zone committee
which ultimately sheltered more than
300,000 refugees in in Nanking and and
those records are still available and in
fact in many different archives and the
diaries of one of the people there at
that of a German Nazi came to light
after I looked and I found his
descendants you know who were living in
Berlin so a lot of the primary source
material was always there and this was
front-page news and in in all the media
at the time but there wasn't that much I
think that had really reached large
numbers of people except for some of
these monographs and in 1996 one a few
months actually before my book came out
she young and James Ian wrote a
pictorial history of The Rape of Nanking
which comprises mainly of photographs
from the massacre it's a very gruesome
book but it must be read and it's very
well documented so and there have been
two novels two that have been produced
at The Rape of Nanking but in general
there hadn't been very much written
about this there's nothing almost in
most school textbooks and done and it's
it's I think there's going to be a
flowering of literature on the subject
in just the next few years last question
yeah well what you were saying in
contrasting the post-war response
Germany Japan is certainly correct there
there of course was as you know a lot of
failure of justice in the Europe in the
German context as well with people like
very nirvan Brown and all kinds of
people oh there's only one solution of
course student but obviously the larger
comparison holds as you said right I
mean there were cold war concerns too
that applied to Germany
exactly it's amazing that there hasn't
been more there have been so much on the
Holocaust
obviously as there should be so little
in contrast it seems and how is that
explicable we have to keep in mind that
China the People's Republic China was
literally sealed off from the rest of
the world for many decades and it was
not until quite recently that an open
exchange of information an open exchange
of you know Commerce and it really you
know it came into being until the 1980s
I think there are many reasons
demographics plays a big role in this I
think that many of the Chinese
immigrants who had come to this country
in the 1960s were primarily in
scientific fields and we're not in a
position to write a book on the subject
I think too that that many of the
academic historians in this country had
a Eurocentric bias when writing World
War two history and therefore ignored
much of the Asian theater of the war and
it's incredible to me that this happened
I mean the International Military
Tribunal of the Far East was the longest
war crimes tribunal in world history and
a reporter who covered it a Brackman
actually who wrote a book about the
subject said he couldn't believe there
was there was almost nothing in the
literature it's almost like the whole
trial had fallen into a big black hole
and he and I find it incredible myself
so there's no shortage of primary source
materials but I think gradually
historians are turning their attention
on the subject and I happen to know at
least 20 books that are probably now
about to be published and are you know
in the research stages on the subject
ask you questions for you one what do
you think of the chance
is realistically of the Japanese facing
up to this in the next few years and
secondly what is the Chinese
government's position in this what are
they actively pursuing any effort to get
this the Japanese to face up to it well
I don't have a crystal ball I mean I
certainly hope that in the next few
years that the Japanese government and
the Japanese people will you know take
greater responsibility for these wartime
crimes but I mean certainly there wasn't
a record of this for the last 60 years I
don't think it's going to happen by
itself I think you could only come about
as a result of media pressure political
pressure a genuine outrage from other
countries and I certainly hope that old
given time the majority of the Japanese
people are going to say it's time for us
to really make a break with the past and
and let's begin the process of healing
by dealing honestly with with the war
now you're asking now what what can be
done what is being done by the People's
Republic of China what's their policy
now I think the best thing to do is
simply to ask them directly I think that
their policy has actually become much
more lenient in terms of permitting
widespread rallies to take place in
China to commemorate the victims of the
Nanking Massacre there is a Nanking
Massacre Museum in the city of Nanjing
and they have permitted much more
research to be done in that country and
they've actually at different times when
I was being denounced by academics or
the Ambassador I mean the PRC government
came out twice to speak out on my behalf
which was a quite of a surprise so I
think that we may see some with some
real shifts in policy in that direction
too but but I think the best way to to
find out really is to ask that the
People's Republic of China
representative directly what what their
policy is terms
we have the same agent and I just
finished writing up writing a book
that's out we have being presented to
publishers now about a man who nobly
indirect through three death camps and a
death march uh-huh I have some idea the
personal cost throwing up sleeplessness
I mean there's there's a tremendous
amount of personal erosion that goes on
and writing a book like this absolutely
I'd like I'd like to know I I know you
had to keep going and obviously you
overcame whatever whatever obstacles you
had I'd like to know literally what
techniques you use to keep yourself from
from going nuts and to keep and to keep
moving and to get get the job done it
was very difficult I mean I had to try
to train myself to come mentalize the
atrocities in one section of my brain so
wouldn't spill over employees and the
other aspects of my life but I sometimes
I found that simply impossible but I
sometimes went days without eating
anything at all because I simply lost my
appetite I was sick physically sick
almost constantly and I lost a great
deal of weight and hair in the process
of writing this book even my editor who
was now my agent Susan rabiner lost ten
pounds just from the process of editing
this book and and she became ill and you
know during the last few stages of the
process and and she couldn't look at the
photos I mean to this day I don't think
she's seen the photos even when I had a
meeting with the art department at basic
books she held up a piece of paper
between herself and photographs that she
wouldn't even catch a glimpse of it by
absent so it's difficult and and the
only thing that kept me going was just
the knowledge that eventually this the
the news of the massacre would reach a
worldwide audience and the victims would
not be forgotten thank you who issued
the order the direct order to kill all
captives is there a name that we can
sort of keep in our minds or is that
group of people well it's it's very
difficult often to assign responsibility
to the highest levels of power and in to
but it appears that the order was issued
under the command
princess akka who was the uncle of
emperor hirohito at the time and
princess akka actually later became
emperor hirohito golfing buddy and was
never prosecuted or even called in to
testify during the International
Military Tribunal the Far East because
he was part of the royal family and
therefore was exonerated from from from
all prosecution and and he lived I think
in in luxury and and you know pretty
much it was was never pretty much
punished for what happened um have any
of the men who participated expressed
remorse and as anyone tried to tell
their story the people asked partier
questions anyone tried to interview them
or tell their story yes in fact the the
first man to publicly apologize for his
misdeeds during the ripening king with
Shira Zuma who I think issued that
apology back in the nineteen 1990s
probably nineteen ninety-one if I
remember correctly and for this who
received so many death threats and so
much hate mail in Japan that he had to
go into hiding and so he retreated from
society and he now lives you know in a
small village where in his house he
compiled the whole arsenal weapons to
defend himself from possible
ultra-nationalist attack and he was
kicked out of his Veterans Association
that had actually you know welcomed him
as a member for more than half a century
and he's been ostracized by friends but
the most disturbing thing is the fact
that he has received countless death
threats but that hasn't prevented him
from unburdening himself you know in
print you know in his conversations with
authors with documentary filmmakers he's
even published his his diary you know in
Japanese a diary he kept during the
Nanking Massacre so I mean I think he in
even though he has committed these acts
of brutality he is
to be commended for his repentant
attitude and there have been some other
sue have done the same who have spoken
out and who apologized and a lot of them
received constant harassment from the
the Japanese right-wing yes you pointed
out that no nation no race no culture is
exempt from the kind of atrocities that
are described here and we know in the
states of course that it's a very
painful process to look back at me lie
to look back at atrocities we've
committed but it is it is accomplished
in a Free Press I've just moved here
from France where curiously it's also
difficult for them to go back even over
recent history the war in Algeria even
recent scandals I don't know of many
nations none of us are exempt from the
atrocities but I think you could
probably count on the fingers of one
hand the places where there are there's
a semblance of a free present and the
process of cauterization is pursued at
least by a small number of journalists
and historians I absolutely agree in
fact there are other countries which not
only refused to acknowledge wrongdoing
or genocide but actually spend millions
of dollars every year trying to spread
propaganda that it never happened I mean
Japan is one country but so is Turkey
you know any Turkey has yet to come to
grips with the the Armenian Genocide
another Holocaust which hasn't really
penetrated I think the mass
consciousness in this country they are
Turkish government has spent millions of
dollars trying to deny this entirely
they've even funded professorships of
leading American universities including
Princeton University and installed
people who do nothing but try to spread
that propaganda and for that reason I
think people it's up to us as individual
human beings as Americans to to remain
ever vigilant of these attempts to
rewrite history because if we don't
speak out other people will try to
dismiss a whole body of evidence
altogether with the policy issue between
the Republic of People's Republic of
China
addressing in or demanding that the
Japanese recognize the sins of the past
because that would open up their own
flaws they might have to re-examine some
that's right in general I find that most
most change comes about from individuals
or from grassroots movements it rarely
comes about from government action and
in general I think international laws
dictated more by money and politics than
it is by justice so I think that
individual efforts such as that of his
you know historians authors or
individual activists or people who are
involved in grassroots movement actually
may make more of a difference than
governments themselves who often aren't
interested in representing the the needs
of the victims or even of their own
constituencies
any other questions it went one more
okay well squeeze one more in I'm asking
a question on the subject of the
graphics I was very lucky in New York to
studied with Peter Watkins who made the
film the war game in England and it was
so graphic that he was banned so I'm
wondering if there ever is a film made
would you control some of the graphics
somehow or oh if there's a Hollywood
studio honestly what I would hope it'd
be a more serious documentary made of it
but if the graphics are very strong well
I know you know what I mean like
Hiroshima me no more that's a very good
point I I think that that was the big
thing that I wrestled with too was how
should I spare the readers the details
you know but I didn't feel it was
important that it was right for me to
censor the information I in so many
cases brutal images did appear in my
book but some of the most graphic
pictures did not any pictures of women
who had been disemboweled after rape I
just I just left out and you're right
there's always that question how much
can people take can the human mind take
and especially when we're dealing with
small children and no school libraries
however in this case in the case with
The Rape of Nanking I mean I've had many
people not just from like the colleges
and universities but from high schools
and grade schools teachers come out and
buy the book and say they're going to
show it to the students and they don't
feel it's too graphic they think it's
necessary for the students to learn what
really happened so it's it's it's always
it's always difficult but in the end I
do think that this is a book that is
it's meant for adult consumption not not
for for children to read and you just
you just do the best and hope you've
made the right decisions thank you very
much thank you
like we
thank you ladies and gentlemen Chang
will autograph books and be able to
speak with you personally outside in the
autograph area